we're also getting some good news this
morning about a potential vaccine from
the pharmaceutical company astrazeneca
we're now joined by dr ashish jah
he's deena brown university school of
public health dr jacques good to see you
this morning
let's talk about the latest news from
astrazeneca which they say has a 70
percent
effectiveness now that sounds good until
you hear about the other two that have a
95 percent effectiveness
tell us why experts are excited about
this one
good morning gail thank you for having
me on uh yeah i think
part of it is we got a little spoiled
right i mean yeah a couple weeks ago i
would have said 70
is a home run 95 from the other two has
really raised the bar
um but the problem here is that there
are two arms of the study
two different dosing regimens one of
them was about sixty percent the other
one was ninety percent we gotta sort out
what happened in the sixty percent arm
but i think this is really good news and
i suspect
we may get to ninety percent on this
vaccine too if we get the dosing right
now scientists are telling us that they
hope to have this vaccine available to
some by december 11th
does that timeline make sense for you
when we're looking at all the drugs that
are
potentially available
it does i mean look we are you know
obviously we've been stockpiling a lot
of these
uh vaccines uh they've got to go through
approval they've got it the data's got
to be reviewed carefully
uh but i think given the urgency of the
time we are in there's no reason to
think we can't get that time approval
i'm sorry that timeline done for
approval by december 11th let's talk
about thanksgiving because we we keep
talking about it the experts keep saying
cancel your plans don't go i'm not
not going to see my kids for the first
time in over a gazillion years which is
very upsetting but that's how it goes
so you're telling people cancel your
plans do not go
clearly a lot of people are not
listening to you sometimes people have
to hear it more than once
what is your message as we sit here
today
yeah so first of all absolutely if you
can avoid traveling for thanksgiving you
absolutely should i see my family every
year we're not doing it this year we're
staying home you know if you have
already committed to going if you've
already left there are things you can do
to make it safer gail
but there are tough things like try to
eat outside wear a mask when you're
inside with your family
not things that we're used to doing
directly what about this if you're going
to eat indoors
yeah but dr john people are saying this
i'm going to take a test
everybody in the house is going to take
a test and so we're all going to gather
together and we've all tested negative
isn't that okay
i wish it was and that makes it better
it's better than not testing at all but
we know like let's say i was infected
yesterday
i could get tested tomorrow i'd be
negative i could travel on wednesday
and by thursday or friday i could be
contagious passing it to other people
this is the problem one negative test
does not buy you out of this
so i think if the strategy is testing
and do then act
normal it's still really risky if you
want to do testing
wearing a mask inside and keeping
windows open to
make sure there's good ventilation like
that might again make it safer but
this is all risky stuff and we're so
close to a vaccine yeah
that i want to make sure that we uh we
get through the holidays and keep people
safe so dr john when you see pictures of
all these people at the airports
what do you think all this travel for
thanksgiving ultimately will mean
for the christmas holiday
yeah what i'm worried about is look
we're already seeing a surge in cases in
large parts of the country
after every holiday over the last six
months we have seen another surge of
cases
i'm worried that what's going to happen
is we're going to see a big bump
hospitals already are strained they're
going to get into
into more trouble and by christmas time
i think we're going to be in a lot of
trouble with a lot of infections a lot
of hospitalizations and a lot of deaths
okay all you can do is put the message
out there and let people make their own
decisions thank you very much dr
zhang